[Music]
everything that you see in your house
that you wear everything is pretty much
been on the back of a truck at some
stage in his life
flu jabs
chicken
and milkshakes just a few of the things
that are currently in short supply in
the uk but i've been here 32 years and
never ever seen anything like this ever
one poll found 56 of people in the uk
have noticed shortages at their local
supermarket we're not getting the stock
so we can't send that out to all the
different places who we supply
so why are there shortages in britain
[Music]
the pandemic has exacerbated a shortage
of lorry drivers in the uk it was an
issue before covid with many drivers
leaving the profession because of the
long hours poor working conditions and
pay declining relative to other
low-skilled trades but with eu nationals
a significant part of the workforce it
became a big deal where many didn't
return and testing for new uk drivers
was put on hold very busy we've got
unprecedented demand for drivers at the
moment the industry has always said that
there's been a shortage of drivers but
now the the supply chain's broken and
supermarket shelves are potentially
empty for christmas then there's brexit
some of the drivers who went home during
the pandemic found themselves unable to
return to the uk because of new
immigration rules around 14 000 eu
drivers left the uk in the year to june
2020 and according to the industry only
600 of them had returned a year later
many brexiteers won't mind that one
argument for leaving the eu was that it
would raise the wages and standards of
domestic workers
the government they're really focusing
on training up domestic people rather
than putting lorry driving on the skill
shortage list to get some of these
european workers back on a work visa
we're going to train up domestic people
it's great for the uk public but that
will take time leaving businesses
struggling to meet demand consumers
facing shortages and potentially price
rises as a consequence in time i think
we can fill the gap but short term i
think we need to maybe relax the visa
rule so we can get some of the eu
drivers back into the uk
long term we'll be fine we just need to
build up to it
[Music]
labor costs are already going up
well we expect to get another
array a wage wage increase imminently
you know our second third in some cases
this year now uh you circle of 10 i
guess as companies struggle to meet
demand drivers have been offered pay
rises in order to ensure they stay in
the profession
and major employers like tesco amazon
and john lewis have offered four-figure
signing on bonuses to new drivers
inducing drivers
football style signing on fees
retention bonuses payable after three
months i've heard numbers up to five
thousand pounds pension
and while hgv drivers are a problem for
everyone there are labour shortages in
other industries too
the confederation of british industries
says there's demand for butchers meat
processors fruit and flower pickers
warehouse workers cleaners chefs
scaffolders carpenters welders
electrical engineers and factory
assembly workers
there are many roles and career
opportunities for local people here but
we simply don't have the people coming
forward for the for the jobs meanwhile
there was still up to 1.6 million people
on furlough at the end of july and the
government hopes that when the scheme
ends this month those made redundant may
fill these roles the cbi is skeptical
the firms that have still got people on
furlough they've been paying for those
so they must be doing so in the belief
that they're going to need those workers
uh pretty soon otherwise they wouldn't
have held on to them and of course
they're going to be some dislocation the
people on that furlough scheme right now
won't necessarily have the skills to
slot straight into these vacancies
[Music]
a shortage of semiconductors the
material from which microchips are made
has hit industries from consumer
electronics to car production initially
the pandemic closed factories in
southeast asia where most semiconductors
are produced then a surge in demand from
people working from home saw them
scramble to meet orders
when the car market recovered faster
than expected chip suppliers couldn't
keep pace
demand is also causing shortages of the
raw materials for the building trade
cement concrete steel stone and timber
prices are rising as a consequence it is
causing product shortages on shelf and
my concern is that this will only get
worse because we're now in september and
we're coming into the critical time of
year where we start to stock build for
christmas
which is obviously a really important
time of year for everyone the cbi warns
that labour shortages could last two
years as employers retrain and hire a
domestic workforce
and some analysts believe that
post-brexit there could be a permanent
impact with reduced supply of goods and
higher prices
[Music]